[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE SAAD CUTHBERTSON: 92%
of the top 125 apps and games
now use Android Studio.
This morning, we'll
release our latest,
which is Android Studio's
2.2 preview, focusing
on speed, smarts, and
Android platform support.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Jamal,
Android Studio 2.2
was announced and
launched today.
Can you give us the highlights?
What are the changes from
Android Studio 2.0 that
are going to make the most
difference in a developer's
experience?
JAMAL EASON: Well, there
are three key things.
First, we talked about
new testing tools.
So the new test recorder
is a really amazing feature
that got a lot of
excitement from developers.
And two was with the
new Layout Editor.
So it actually
introduces a new layout.
So instead of worrying about all
the different nested layouts,
you have one flat layout
that's actually more performant
and more dynamic.
And number three,
enhanced C++ support.
Now we support hybrid
debugging, and support
for ndk-build and CMake builds.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really great.
I think one of the things we've
been hearing from developers
for a long time is
more C++ support.
It gives them a stronger
ability to build cross-platform
and make sure that that
code that they're building
can apply more to their
Android apps as well.
JAMAL EASON: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In
fact, especially,
game developers have been
asking about it as well.
I can't wait to see
what they'll do with it.
JAMAL EASON: Absolutely.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Is there anything
else that developers should
do besides downloading
Android Studio 2.2 and
giving us feedback?
JAMAL EASON: I think that's it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Jamal, thanks
so much for joining us today.
JAMAL EASON: Not a problem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]